Qué significa la llegada de Georgia
meloni al poder en Italia
significa la llegada de por primera vez
de la historia de la República italiana
de una mujer en el cargo del clima
ministro es una fecha absolutamente
súper importante y luego he escuchado lo
que han dicho antes es un error
verdaderamente catastrófico decir que
este es un gobierno de ultradereza esta
es una típica derechas conservadora y
como en Italia estamos en una democracia
en una República democrática con la
alternancia de poderes Es lógico que
luego de 11 años del gobierno
entre un populismo y una izquierda entre
comillas que más izquierda de radical
chica que han puesto Italia en la peor
crisis luego del posguerra
la gente votando haya pretendido una
alternancia de poderes claro guido
hablamos de extrema derecha precisamente
por su retórica abiertamente
por el hecho de que dentro de los
hermanos de Italia hay aduladores
abiertamente de El fascista Benito
Mussolini pero pasemos a otro tema y es
que finalmente fuerza Italia se ha
quedado con el Ministerio de exteriores
no encabezado por Antonio tajani quien
por un lado ha ocupado altos cargos en
la Unión Europea Pero por otro lado es
el segundo de civil vio verloscony quien
ha estado en el centro de la polémica
esta semana después de que la pre se
filtrará unos audios en que habla de su
buena amistad con Putin que hay que
esperar entonces de la relación entre
Roma y Bruselas En este gobierno
a la relación entre Roma y Bruselas
depende de la voluntad de los de las dos
partes de establecerlas porque hay que
recordar que
también mientras había en curso las
elecciones o pocos días antes la
presidenta
vonderro abiertamente y con la
injerencia que no haya sido mal
soportada por toda la instituciones
políticas italianas que se lleva a
formar un gobierno que a la Unión
Europea no le gustaba se iban a poner en
contra Entonces se tendrá que establecer
una relación una buena pero muchas cosas
habrán de que mudar también en la Unión
Europea misma porque no es una mega
coincidencia sin muchos países gobiernos
de derechos
están
encabezando varias naciones eso
significa que la política de la Unión
Europea y la la misma Unión Europea
tiene que cambiar algo y no puede seguir
así siendo una Unión
básicamente en primer lugar financiera
más que política y políticas del bien
común como todos los europeos se
esperaban y para cerrar rápidamente
qué estabilidad le augura a esta
coalición a gubernamental no siendo
Italia un país tan conocido precisamente
por su inestabilidad en el ejecutivo
cruzando la peor crisis luego de
posguerra entonces este gobierno tiene
que tomar medidas ya o sea mañana tienen
que aparecer mi vida también si el
domingo porque en primer lugar tienen
que hacer algo para reducir las boletas
espantosa que estamos recibiendo y
estamos en la situación en la cual 160
mil empresas italianas están abiertos de
cierre Entonces estamos en una situación
de desastre prácticamente y se tiene que
operar a toda velocidad y esperar que
este gobierno
pueda mantener toda la promesa que eso
es su campaña electoral porque es por
eso que la mayoría de los italianos los
vota